we begin this half-hour with the
controversial meeting between President
Trump and Philippine president Rodrigo
Duterte
it comes as duterte continues to
cultivate a violent image on Friday he
told an audience he committed murder at
age 16 and since taking office last year
Duterte is following through on his
campaign promise to purge the
Philippines of illegal drug use it's a
pledge that's come with a price of
thousands of lives lost as kylie atwood
reports from Manila it's almost 3:00 in
the morning here in Manila and we're
seeing the results of new territories
were on drugs and his pledge to kill to
slaughter all drug users police are
responding to the murder of a drug user
and we're gonna go see the scene when
there's something happen here to watch
them who was there waiting here to see
who died who was killed
we're told that there's one person who
was killed and that he was killed by
policemen the man was an alleged drug
user
they said they shot him in self-defense
it was one of nine killings across
Manila that night a new reality here
since doTERRA today's election a
president vowing to rid the country of
three million drug addicts by any means
necessary this is what makes the
Philippines drug war different former
police officers say when Duterte was
mayor of Davao City
he paid death squads to kill both drug
dealers and users several local
residents introduced us to a hitman he
says this cash for murder practice
continues please
that was us we didn't know it but he
came to the interview with a gun in his
satchel what's in your bag ich bin it's
engraved the enforcer for every murder
with that gun he says the police pay him
and his partner $400 so it's the
government paying you yes ma'am
from duterte he sees I'm the president
the Philippines recently experienced the
bloodiest period in its war on drugs
58 dead in just three days this summer
but crime was down into ter days first
year by nine percent there are less
crime happening in the Philippines
there's a better crime environment and
this is a result this is a consequence
of the focused campaign against illegal
drugs DiNardo Carlos is the spokesperson
for the Philippine National Police
despite to tear ties public comments
endorsing the killing of drug users
Carlos says the police follow the rule
of law and they're not hiring hitmen
people out in the communities here say
that there are rogue hitmen who are
killing drug users and they're backed by
the police what do you say to that
okay these are all allegations
they have to prove that we are
conducting motor propio investigation
when there is a a debt or the hitmen who
are wearing masks and out killing people
are they lying when they say that
they're backed by the police we don't we
don't employ we do not use the same as
men or vigilante group on the whole do
you think that this effort has been
successful we are looking at the two
main objective have we reduced the
number of drug personalities of drug
users and lessen the demand have we
accomplished our our target yes we did
we embedded with the Kazon city police
outside of Manila on a daily anti-drug
operation going house-to-house rounding
up drug users we are going to convince
them to surrender fearful faces lined
the streets as the police shuffle
through at our third stop a child cried
as the police took away her father for
drug testing this is how far do ter taze
drug war reaches the man had not been
caught with drugs he was on a list of
suspected users created by local
community leaders minutes later the
police announced their round was done it
appeared to us the operation was cut
short because they didn't want us to see
much more of the turmoil that follows
their raids you said if we were gonna go
to 20 houses we only went to for so many
house we need to finish the houses not
advice because we passed the we passed
by the house I didn't see you go into
any other houses except three because I
don't want you to cut this short because
we're with you and it seems that that's
what you're doing they've got the house
we have so many house it's already you
told me 20 houses we went to phone three
or four no pink we didn't go to the
whole list his whole list you see when
does this end we want to end it by
having no demand and no supply in the
country that's rich that's a hundred
percent for CBS this morning Saturday
Kylie Atwood Manila Philippines
yeah murdering drug users is a shocking
tactic if that's what's being and
especially when they're put on lists you
know without any real accusations
shocking yeah